[Music]
on this sunday night changing tactics in
ukraine
russia targets food and gas supplies in
the west as officials warn of a plan to
split ukraine in two and the kremlin
fires back after biden's heated remarks
against vladimir putin it could
complicate matters going down the road
touchdown in rome canada's indigenous
delegation arrives in vatican city
unbelievable i don't know like i'm in a
daze we are on the ground in italy with
the group in search of accountability
the only time an apology is going to
come is if the catholic church feels
that it's back into a corner and oh
canada hitting home pitch in hopes of
clinching a spot at the world cup for
the first time in over three decades
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
dallas flex
fresh images from ukraine's port city of
mariupol show the utter ruins it is now
in ukraine's deputy prime minister today
saying the southeastern hub simply does
not exist anymore
good evening and thank you for joining
us ukrainian officials say russian
attacks have destroyed 85 percent of
marijuana some say it is now only a
matter of time before it falls to the
russians
you have the situation in mariupol which
has become a bit of a ukrainian alamo at
this point in time it's fighting to the
last defender
and pinning down multiple russian
battalions in so doing very heroically
but ultimately it looks as if it's going
to have to to collapse it's going to be
taken
meantime we are learning more about the
destruction left behind after rockets
landed yesterday in la vie a fuel depot
and military factory were targeted in
the fiercest attacks yet on the western
city which up until this weekend was
considered a safe haven for ukrainians
fleeing the war as david aiken reports
ukraine says russia is now changing its
strategy as it looks to split the
country apart
more than 20 thousand people once lived
here in volnovaka a small town in
ukraine's eastern donext region now it's
a ghost town nearly destroyed by russian
munitions and now ukraine's military
intelligence directorate says russia is
planning to split ukraine in two with
what the ukrainians called the korean
scenario but while the korean peninsula
was frozen into its north-south
configuration by war in the 1950s russia
is aiming for west east folding regions
like donetsk into some kind of new
country ukrainian military forces are
doing everything they can to prevent
that and on sunday ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky released another video
asking the west yet again that his
military forces be given tanks and
planes and he angrily taunted nato
powers who have so far ignored those
requests saying
so who is running the euro atlanta
community is it still moscow because of
threats
zielinski's demand for help came after
russian cruise missiles hit a fuel
storage facility in levive no deaths
have been reported but firefighters
spent all night putting the blaze out a
ukrainian government official said this
is a new twist to russia's attacks
aiming at fuel and food storage centers
which would force the ukraine government
to disperse stocks of both
zielenski also had a warning for putin
that his invasion and the continued and
indiscriminate shelling of civilians was
sowing a deep hatred among ukrainians
for the russian people
putin too had his own video
congratulating members of the russian
national guard for what putin called
their professionalism and bravery in
operations in ukraine western
intelligence sources though say russia
has lost as many as 15 000 troops killed
in just four weeks of war including
seven generals though russia has
admitted none of those deaths nato
leaders believe those kind of steep
losses could force putin to take even
more dangerous and radical steps as the
war enters its second month
david aiken global news
the white house is walking back comments
made by joe biden during his fiery
speech to the world last night where he
denounced vladimir putin the u.s
president seemed to suggest a regime
change was in order for russia as he
promised continued support for ukraine
administration officials now say those
comments were ad-libbed and that there
is no plan to pursue that but that
hasn't stopped the kremlin from firing
back jennifer johnson has the latest
[Applause]
now back in washington the white house
is clarifying an off the cuff remark u.s
president joe biden made during a speech
in poland seeming to suggest it was time
for the russians to force president
vladimir putin out
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power the comment seemed to be a direct
call for regime change in russia white
house officials were quick to clear up
any confusion we do not have a strategy
of regime change in russia or anywhere
else for that matter it's up to the
people of the country in question it's
up to
the russian people the president did
extend an olive branch to the russian
people telling them they are not the
enemy the kremlin shot back saying it's
up to russian citizens to elect their
president but under putin's rule
elections have not been fair or free his
political opponents are often jailed or
silenced although some world leaders
believe this war could cost putin his
job the russian people i think are
pretty fed up
with what is happening
in ukraine this illegal invasion the
destruction of their own livelihoods
their economy
is collapsing around them before and
during the war the u.s has repeatedly
asked putin to come to the negotiating
table find a diplomatic way out
while france's president is calling for
this situation not to get out of control
others believe putin won't forget what
biden said it will play on his mind and
it could complicate matters going down
the road
still others say biden was just voicing
the hopes of millions around the world i
think many people will sympathize with
the sentiments
that led him to say what he did for now
the white house is sticking to its
statement that the u.s will not be
involved in any regime change in russia
instead the administration is moving
ahead with its strategy of cutting off
putin his billionaire backers and the
russian economy from the rest of the
world
jennifer johnson global news washington
today pope francis stepped up his calls
for further negotiations to end the
fighting in ukraine
during his sunday blessing the pope
warned it's time to abolish war before
war wipes out humanity since russia
invaded ukraine over a month ago francis
has criticized moscow and condemned what
he calls an unjustified aggression but
he has not cited russia by name as the
aggressor
and pope francis is getting ready to
meet with canadian indigenous leaders
who have now arrived in rome for these
historic meetings the 32 delegates will
push for an apology for the abusive
residential school system in canada run
largely by the catholic church global's
nathu garcia is in rome tonight nithu
dallas there are delegates who had never
left canada before this and some say
coming to another country let alone
meeting with the head of the catholic
church to advocate for tangible change
for their people is both overwhelming
and a source of optimism all at once
unbelievable
i just not
i don't know like i'm in a daze
this will be a watershed week in the
effort to advance reconciliation that's
what one of the delegates said about the
hopeful impact of this trip shortly
after touching down in rome with a group
of more than 60 others from canada 32 of
them are delegates from first nations
inuit and metis communities the rest are
their family members close friends staff
and mental health support workers they
arrived shortly before pope francis gave
his regular weekly address there was no
mention of the indigenous delegation
traveling here to meet him but as he
gave this speech the kind he's often
used in past years to emphasize the
importance of listening his chance to
truly practice what he preaches begins
on monday
delegates will make multiple asks to
support long-term healing including a
formal apology for the residential
school system that left a lasting legacy
of trauma and violent racism amounting
to genocide according to a 2019 inquiry
into missing and murdered indigenous
women and girls
now elders like angie creer will share
their stories inevitably showcasing
their strength at a time of reckoning
when more people than ever before are
listening
nobody wanted us
oh the white don't want you there
nothing indian don't want you nobody
wants here nobody will ever
belong to anyone
i got news for them
i have an identity
i've learned my mutination of alberta
two of the three groups the inuit and
metis will have separate morning sit
downs with the pontiff on monday it
marks the start of the largest ever
delegation from canada to vatican city
for private meetings with pope francis
for many their healing hinges on not
only being heard but also what happens
after this trip
dallas
lithu garcia in rome thanks
a 24-hour crisis line is available to
support residential school survivors the
number is toll free and you can speak in
confidence that number is 1-800-721-0066
it has been decades since one of
canada's largest sex abuse scandals was
exposed at the mount castle orphanage
for boys in newfoundland and labrador
more than 100 boys were physically and
sexually abused by members of the
christian brothers who were hired by the
catholic church many of those boys who
are now elderly men are only now
receiving compensation and as ross lord
reports the catholic church is looking
at a unique source to help make the
payments
when a chase the ace lottery raised
almost 6 million dollars for maintaining
their catholic church people in the st
john's neighborhood of goulds had no way
of knowing this feel-good story might
turn out bad the proceeds could be
earmarked for a different purpose
compensating victims of physical and
sexual abuse at the mount castle
orphanage a tough sell to parishioners i
don't think it should be used for that i
think it should go to what it was
intended for i don't think that we the
people of the ghouls or anybody else who
participated in
such an event should be responsible to
pay for
the victims
after its liability for the abuse was
confirmed last year the catholic
episcopal corporation of saint john's
has been scrambling for ways to pay
claims that could run into the tens of
millions of dollars the chase the ace
windfall would help the situation is
pretty unusual in fact i would say it's
unprecedented in this entire country
the episcopal corporation has also filed
for creditor protection listing 19
church properties that could be sold off
including a local landmark the basilica
of saint john the baptist
in a statement delivered to churchgoers
during weekend mass archbishop peter
hunt confirmed the court approved a sale
by tender process for the major church
properties in the greater saint john's
area including the basilica and some
cemeteries a peculiar offshoot of an
abuse scandal that's dragged on for
decades it's been quite a struggle over
many years it has had
strange detours the chase the ace one is
one of the stranger ones but
here we are with an awkward court battle
looming there's been another surprise a
settlement a resolution was reached
whereby
some of the
millions of dollars in that chase the
ace account will be paid to
saint kevin's parish the rest of the
money will go to the victims although
the amounts are being kept a secret
other legal and financial hurdles remain
and an even bigger challenge is moving
past the mount castle scandal once and
for all the social
and emotional
aspects of it are not going to be
resolved anytime soon if ever the
lingering damage from a devastating
chapter in newfoundland history
ross lord global news
search crews combing the debris field of
last week's china eastern plane crash
that killed all 132 people on board have
recovered the second black box the
flight data recorder was found 40 meters
from the plane's point of impact buried
more than a meter underground the
cockpit voice recorder was retrieved on
wednesday recovering both black boxes
increases the chance investigators will
be able to determine the cause of the
crash
footage shows the boeing maid 737 nose
diving before slamming into a
mountainside in southern china on monday
leaving a 20 meter crater in the ground
in the u.s colorado fire crews battling
a fast-moving wildfire threatening lives
on the outskirts of boulder are gaining
ground
evacuation orders were lifted today
after the wildfire burned within 900
meters of homes forcing some 19 thousand
residents to flee the area on saturday
the site of the wildfire is near the
scene of a destructive blaze that
destroyed more than a thousand homes
back in december going back to the table
ukraine and russia will meet again next
week how hopeful anyone is for mediation
as leaders in and outside of nato try
and bridge the gap in this war
[Music]
a historic summit hosted by israel
involving top diplomats from the u.s and
four arab league countries got underway
today it's the first time foreign
ministers from the uae morocco and
bahrain will meet their israeli
counterpart in his home country
egypt a longtime peace partner of israel
is also there for the talks which are
aimed at realigning relations among
middle eastern powers accelerated by the
war in ukraine
ukrainian officials say they will once
again hold in-person meetings with a
russian delegation next week although it
remains unclear where those talks will
take place negotiations between the two
sides have so far gotten nowhere despite
offers and efforts from other countries
to mediate as redmond shannon takes a
look at which nations may be in the best
place to help broker retruce as the war
marches on into its second month
vladimir putin's long meeting table was
both comic and tragic an illustration of
the diplomatic distance between russia
and the west in the lead up to the
invasion the pre-war efforts of france's
emanuel macron came to nothing despite
years of french involvement in peace
talks for the breakaway portion of the
donbass region which russia recognized
as independent before launching its
ukraine invasion still he continues to
engage with putin i think it's useful
for the americans actually for other
europeans to have at least one leader
that is in contact with with mr putin
even if on the surface there might be
some tensions there another nato member
attempting mediation is turkey hosting a
summit between ukraine and russia's
foreign ministers two weeks ago turkey
has a complex relationship with russia
it has not imposed sanctions but it has
restricted black sea access to russian
warships
thursday's nato summit turkish president
erdogan was eager to stress nato poses
no direct threat to russia but turkey
has sold drones to ukraine turkey has
deep economic interests here the
political engagement i think the
ukrainians trust turkey and after all
they have hosted already a senior level
meeting a possible mediator outside nato
is israel prime minister naftali bennett
visited putin in moscow this month
bennett says it's his moral duty to help
israel and russia have common enemies in
the war in syria and it has strong ties
to jewish diasporas in both russia and
ukraine putin claimed the invasion was
to denazify ukraine but it has forced
thousands of jews to flee how we can
bring about a ceasefire pakistan's
leader imran khan has suggested islamic
countries and china get involved
likely unappealing to vladimir zelinski
because many of those nations abstained
from a u.n resolution condemning the
invasion ukraine's president insists he
wants to meet with putin zalenski will
go into this very hem then because
there's no way he can agree to many of
the concessions that we know russia is
putting forth giving uh you know
recognition of crimea as russian
territory recognition of the gumballs
for now it appears guns missiles and
bombs are doing all the talking redmond
shannon global news london
the world is watching and the vatican
knows it ahead how the push for an
official papal apology from canada's
indigenous delegation could be seen
around the world
when indigenous leaders meet with pope
francis this week they will be looking
to get a long-awaited apology from the
catholic church for its role in canada's
abusive residential school system as
crystal gomezing reports experts are
divided as to whether those demands will
finally be met
assimilation to white society
colonialism that robbed generations of
indigenous children of their basic right
to exist
a theft of dignity and culture
after decades of harm first nations
inuit and metis people are again looking
to the roman catholic church to make
amends
they
want to use that moment
justifiably
and see the vatican as a symbol of
western culture
of western domination
of colonialism of the white race
basically professor of theology massimo
faggioli says he will be closely
following the meetings indigenous
delegates will have with pope francis
in the days ahead
it has
a global meaning and this is why the
vatican has i believe studied
this request and this opportunity
carefully because
they knew that
it was
much bigger than a
local
catholic or national issue
[Laughter]
last year the world's eyes opened to the
atrocities indigenous people suffered in
canada when hundreds of unmarked graves
were discovered in british columbia and
saskatchewan a galvanizing social
justice moment and rallying cry that
every child matters
pope benedict the 16th previously
expressed sorrow for the deplorable
abuses that took place in residential
schools his successor pope francis
expressed a similar statement
neither one said sorry michelle good
says words
i think that the only time an apology is
going to come is if the catholic church
feels that it's backed into a corner
goode is the daughter of a survivor an
award-winning author and former lawyer
who fought for compensation for
survivors
when they're there
i hope
that
the indigenous people that go will take
a tour of the vatican museum and i hope
that they look at nero's bathtub which
has been valued at 60 billion dollars
and all the church would have to do is
give up nero's bathtub and they could
compensate survivors royally
32 survivors knowledge keepers and
elders will meet with the pope each has
their own view of success but the world
is watching
crystal gamson global news london
canada's men's soccer team made history
tonight punching its ticket to the 2022
world cup in front of a home crowd in
toronto
the atmosphere outside and inside [ __ ]
stadium nothing short of electric
thousands of fans showing up in full
force chanting and cheering on canada's
men's team which will play in a world
cup for the first time since 1986
after beating jamaica for nil
we'll be cheering them on at that world
cup that is global national for this
sunday night i'm dallas flex and tonight
we leave you with more
jubilant scenes from the world cup
qualifier in toronto congratulations to
canada's men's team and for those of you
watching at home
thanks for watching
have a good night
[Music]
you